foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships number one
best-selling author host of the smart
money happy hour photos this month
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
at AAA
[Music]
825-5225-88-825-5225 Olivia starts off
this hour in Columbia South Carolina hi
Olivia welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you
thank you sure what's up
so I get like a separate line out of my
paycheck for six hundred dollars for a
car allowance every month I have to have
a car nearer than five years I've been
pushing it to your I'm on your seven and
they're just now saying like you need a
new car so I'm trying to decide if I
should just like say never mind don't
give it to me anymore because we've been
throwing it at our debt because we're in
baby step two we're gonna be done either
in a month or December or should we sell
my husband's truck
because he has a work car that's you can
use for personal use it's in his
contract it's totally fine and then buy
a new car with like the rest of that or
I don't I just don't know what to do
well you don't have to buy a new car
just a newer car correct yeah yeah newer
than five years to keep that or is it
even worth it I have a great 2016 Honda
Civic
[Music]
because if you keep the car
what ends up the the your employer yeah
she lives at 600 bucks a month right
yeah that's it yes and the in the gas
card which would kind of suck because I
um I use about 300 a month in gas for my
job
oh so it's 900 bucks
yeah if you think about yeah because my
gas is free for all my business use I'll
I fill it up personally though okay so
that's what 11 500 a year yes
um and your what would it cost you to
move up in car three years so that
you're one year inside of the
you got a four-year-old car
[Music]
no
no have you even looked
no because I was just thinking I was
just gonna forgo it um no I think you're
gonna do it I think you're going to do
it I think you're gonna I think you're
what your husband's trucks sell for
um 30 on Kelly blue books oh okay and
it's paid for wow okay yeah we just have
the student loan the one student loan
left and your student loans how much
17 the last one and your household
income is what
um 140. wow okay you guys were doing
great Olivia um we're like and someone
gave us yours yeah so 11 what I'm just
doing math 11 000 a year or not
okay so if we sell the truck and pay off
the student loan and use the remaining
money and sell your car and move up a
little bit in car we get an extra eleven
thousand dollars a year and we're out of
debt
and he needs a car though no he's got a
car he's got a company car he's allowed
to drive yeah okay drive it out wherever
he wants to yeah
I'm doing that Olivia yeah that's my
opinion I'm gonna start I'm gonna dump
his truck take out the student loan put
the other 13 with your car you don't
have to spend it all on a car but um but
move up in car you know a little bit
enough to get back in this because
they're basically saying we're going to
pay you eleven thousand dollars so if
you move up eleven thousand dollars in
car
you broke even the first year on that
okay
so I think this is a keeper it's yeah
and that's not and by the way what
they're what they're asking you to do is
not unusual
most car allowances do have a mileage
and a year model
uh floor they will not let you go below
and they they've let you get away with
it for two years
because it's not because they're stupid
it's just because they in in you know
they've run some statistical analysis
and if they're going to pay for your car
they don't want you in a hoopty that's
breaking down because you're supposed to
get to work
okay that's what that's what the purpose
of that is it's not random so yeah it's
not a bad gig and you're driving a lot
oh yeah I'm like working with right at
200 000 miles right now yeah oh dang
yeah so whatever you you don't want to
move up too much in car because what
you're Road Warriors so whatever you
drive you destroy its value with the
mileage
yeah so I'm gonna move up to a
three-year-old what are you you said
you're driving a Honda what a Civic yeah
move up to a three-year-old Civic
whatever the difference is in that and
yours you should be able to pay that out
of what's left over after paying off the
student loans on the truck how much can
you sell yours for Olivia
um when I did the Kelly Blue books it
was like 3 500 bucks
14 with 3 500 will get you up to where
I'm talking about
okay thank you so
you said Thank You Well Done Olivia yeah
she's on it I had a girl on my uh I did
an Instagram live with the car Mom it's
the girl she's a young mom and she's
built this huge following because she
goes in as a mom and goes and walks
through all these cars right like she
gives you tours of cars and this whole
thing
um our mom is a car expert yes that's
cool yeah she grew up her dad owns a car
dealership so she grew up around cars so
she's like kind of taking this on and
it's and she's like got this great
following and everything so good good
for her but we were talking about used
cars but she was still saying like with
repos being high and because people
taking out loans on new cars still the
used car market is like it's still on
fire she was like it is still so
difficult and so just as a word out
there for people if you know you have to
replace your car in the next six months
start searching now like start actually
doing the research looking saving and
all of it because and don't get in a
panic yes don't yeah be prepared because
it's still I mean there's it's still
it's crazy it's not like it was but it
is no it's not like it's not back
the market is not flooded with used cars
either so right exactly yeah still
interesting yeah very fun open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five not traditionally not counting the
uh the burp in the market after covid
supply chain stuff okay when you when
the Mississippi ran backwards and used
cars went up in value okay I mean this
was a weird moment in history and an
anomaly statistically okay so not
counting that the new car market has
traditionally lost 70 to 80 percent of
its value in the first four years
and so they go down in value Like a Rock
that's where Chevy got that like a rock
okay and so and I'm gonna show you guys
so it's okay and Ford's no better it's
found on the road depreciated so there
you go and uh they all if it has wheels
it has a motor
has a battery it's going down in value
now what we're saying is it was a period
of time where it actually went up for a
short period of time prices went up
everything went backwards in coveted for
a minute there remember that and then
now we're back to more normal but it
hadn't cooled completely off is what
you're saying yeah yeah and I was
looking at some stuff even online
um just after we talked and I was like
oh yeah like I mean you can find stuff
but it's really difficult but also the
encouraging thing is cars today she was
like cars that have 200 000 miles
they're not breaking down those are good
quality cars so that's another good
thing is that they last you so much
longer than they used to yeah they don't
build them like they used to thank God
good thank God that's right yeah these
actually have disc brakes and stuff you
know good gosh wow I got a 1960 Corvette
you can't stop that thing in a 10 acre
field I mean you just kind of have to
let it Coast to a stop it's unbelievable
very nice to drive around a little
antique but
the new one is a lot better this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
rather
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
forty percent off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today Chris is in Charlotte
North Carolina hi Chris welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up um I'll get right to it um me and my
wife recently started a side business we
both work full-time and kind of looking
to pay off a ton of Consumer Debt and
realize you can only save so much so we
we started this side business dog
sitting with the intentions of paying
off the Consumer Debt and I spoke with
my accountant last year
um and he suggested putting my two
children kind of on payroll right and
paying them to benefit
um you know investing into their Roth
IRA and maxing out for them because he
suggested that you know they don't pay
taxes on that
um so that now kind of threw me for a
loop and I think that's what we're going
to plan on doing for this year and and
my question is we are pretty late to the
game with investing for ourselves right
and it kind of I wonder if it's foolish
to do that for them I I just recently
learned the power of compounding
interest so that's the reason why I'm
doing this you know and there are three
and five
um it just seemed like a unique
opportunity because we don't plan on
doing this forever really just to pay
off the Consumer Debt and we're not
really
struggling we have a plan you know to
pay off the Consumer Debt and if it
takes a little bit longer because we're
paying our children investing in a Roth
IRA
I'm an IRS auditor and I'm sitting in
front of you
and you paid your three-year-old
to do work
I'm not believing that the
three-year-old did any work and I'm
gonna undo everything you did
in the audit You're Gonna Lose
your accountant is a
you have to be able to you have to be
able to be working if the child is
actually working you can pay them the
market value for their work
but you can't make a case that a
three-year-old is actually working
be struggling to say a five-year-old it
happens to be walking dogs so we can do
this now an exception would be like I
did have a client one time who had a
baby who appeared in multiple diaper
commercials and made serious Bank the
baby was actually working and so yeah we
put that into an IRA for sure because of
the power of compound interest but what
you you have to be able to make the case
that they were paid
you know I like Rachel for instance at
14 years old would go and do a
three-minute talk on the stage of why
it's tough to be Dave Ramsey's daughter
eight minutes what it was like eight
minutes eight minutes okay I
I'm sorry sorry we would work the events
though yeah it was not eight hours it
was a few minutes okay and and then she
would go work the book tables and I
would pay her a percentage of what the
kids books sold at the book tables back
then and she's a teenager and and it was
it was a healthy percentage but I didn't
pay her a hundred thousand dollars a
year
you couldn't justify that to an auditor
you follow me so I mean yeah you know so
you can't do that the dog sitting I mean
it really is it's not you know feed the
dogs watch the dogs play with the dogs
three-year-olds are not allowed to work
okay I mean really think just use some
common sense okay yeah yeah what could
what would you actually if you ran a
business would you actually hire the
neighborhood
three-year-old to go over no you
wouldn't yeah I might hire the
neighborhood eight-year-old to help me
and there's a market value to that doing
dog sitting okay and you can actually
make a common sense case for that yeah
but the three-year-old still barely
potty trained oh my God and now we're
trying to potty train dogs no no no no
no no no no no no no no this doesn't
work so you know they so your accountant
is willing to set you up for losing an
audit which is why I'm saying I don't
think you need this accountant and Chris
and here's the deal too even if you wait
ill there
12 14 years old to start this project
process they're gonna be fine like
they're gonna be fine you don't have to
start at three you know so you can do
this in a morally legal way eventually
that's that's great what he's saying
that he's going to not do the dog
sitting thing after he gets out of debt
so it's not the opportunity's not going
to be there no I'm just saying in
general though like in general they can
go and like y'all could start something
or you know whatever life looks like
when they're act when they actually are
able to contribute and it's not like
you're kind of you know and you don't
need to be behind on your investing
when I did this for our three kids you
have to file a tax return on the kid and
there is some taxes due okay there's no
income tax to you but they're going to
get hit with FICA and uh self-employed
income and so each one of them I filed a
tax return I looked at their actual
income I had to make sure it was market
value or slightly above market value for
the duty that they were performing and I
filed a tax return I paid the taxes they
kept the money that they earned and I
put the equivalent amount into a Roth
IRA on their behalf all of them were
teenagers by the time we were doing that
yeah and
um or thereabouts I mean Daniel might
have been 12 I mean or something but but
uh
I mean they were you had a justifiable
case and we were baby step seven and my
investments were okay I didn't do this
kind of stuff you know and then my and
then I'm going to retire broke but my
kid has a 16 year old has an IRA no
rights right yeah it's a balance and
again Chris I think the urgency that
you're feeling is I mean he just said
he's like I just learned about compound
interest oh my gosh exciting yeah so
there is an urgency and I think you know
again the heart behind it's incredible
absolutely and to be able to set our
kids up really well and there's time to
do that is what I would say so don't let
this urgency of this new information
make you make bad decisions and lead you
into something that's just not wise how
often do they audit well I mean if the
thing is you the point is not are you
going to get no no I know I know there's
like a moral thing here but but when you
said that I was like man I wonder how
often like
well you just you have to be able to
defend everything you do in an auditor
you shouldn't be doing it yes totally so
that's not only it's not only proper tax
process but it's also the moral and
ethical thing totally yes yes for sure
like we've just finished this
unbelievable two and a half year audit
just similar to an anal exam at Ramsay
and so uh but we have paid every
stinking dime that we've ever owed and
so we've not lost a single category not
a single category and they've turned
over everything in this building
um you know and uh you know so but but
we're Fanatics about paying the exact
thing amounts everything being honest
every bit of cash we collect is taxable
income we don't have any side gigs going
every it's very traceable and it has
nothing to do with I like taxes or I
think taxes are wonderful or it's my way
of being generous it's not taxes are
extortion they're theft by your
government they're horrible I hate them
I hate the IRS but it has nothing to do
with that it has to do with my Integrity
it says it doesn't say anything about
them when I cheat on my taxes or
something about me
and so Chris that's not aiming at you
but that's just a further soapbox on
this whole thing so good motivation bad
information
good thoughts bad timing
so later on when you're at baby step
seven and you've got and your
retirement's underway and you can do
justifiable market value labor for your
kid like if your kid is 16 in a few
years and they're doing it they got this
wonderful dog sitting business that they
spring up because Mom and Dad used to do
it and they go make a bunch of money you
could do what I did with our kids and
it'd be perfectly fine no issues there
at all and you'll be teaching them
entrepreneurism in their teens which is
a great idea so that's the kind of thing
you're looking for bad timing though you
can't unless the three-year-old's in a
diaper commercial three-year-olds don't
have a market pull-up commercial
pull-ups okay at three yeah hopefully
hopefully yeah that's good we're in the
middle of that we have a three and a
half year old I thought oh you just once
you don't want Charles watching your dog
now Amelia the eight-year-old oh yeah
she would be yeah she's pretty she knows
how to take care of Jim better than I do
I mean she's pretty much game on yeah
phenomenal but not the three-year-old no
no they're yeah I'm not gonna say it
okay they're just they're fine they're
fun that's what we're gonna say what are
you gonna say no I just I was saying
about all of them not just not just that
one Dave likes babies Papa Dave wants
babies once they hit like two when
they're doing the pull-ups
I'm good that's completely until you can
ski yes yeah
there's a transition period there this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today hey guys we get people
that tune into the show every day you
can even answer the questions faster
than we can
not a fairly fairly predictable answer
but yeah I mean you can't and then and
you're still stressed out about money
and your money's still not working how
is that well because knowing what to do
is way different than actually doing it
I know not to eat a box of chocolate
donuts
it's important though that I don't do it
otherwise I get larger and larger
versions of Dave and The Proven way to
change your behavior with money is the
same thing is you have to get plugged
into a program Financial Peace
University has helped over 10 million
people get out of debt become wealthy
and change their family trees the class
is the difference between trying to get
in shape by yourself or reading a book
on Fitness versus actually going for a
walk and backing off from the donuts hey
that's why this class has worked for
Millions after nine weeks you'll never
handle money the same way again and
you'll make progress faster than ever
don't just listen to this stuff this
show do it
join a Financial Peace University class
at
ramsaysolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com Financial Peace
University FPU Ryan's in Tampa hey Ryan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Rachel thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
so my question is should I sell my house
should my wife and I sell our house to
pay off our debt
um and a little bit of backstory is
um we're a family of five and we're
currently living in a q Warren
is that what you said two bedroom one
bath
yes we're in a 2-1
um so and we have 83 000 worth of debt a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
equity
um so our thought processes if we still
learn how we need we need a bigger house
we've got three kids so
um and our thought processes if we sell
our house we can pay off the debt have
enough money for our emergency fund
because we're currently in baby step two
and then grant for a couple years and
just do baby step 3B
how long have you been married
eight eight years how long you been in
this house
three years
how long you been working this plan this
Ramsey stuff
this Ramsey stuff I've been Dave ish for
what we've done we've been in Davis for
a couple years the no when did you start
actually getting so serious that you're
willing to sell your house
oh a couple weeks ago okay
how much you guys make a year Ryan
uh eighty thousand
eighty thousand okay
okay here I I'm I'm nervous that the
reason you want to sell the house is
more because you don't like the house
not necessarily to
change the behavior to get out of debt
yeah
so like this would be like a silver
bullet that would just like fix it all
but what I would be worried about Ryan
is like have you guys fixed your
behavior like have you have you guys
created you don't ever felt the
sacrifice of new habits and you don't
have that change that course you don't
have the track record of new habits
that's the danger and if if you wave
this magic wand and your debt is gone
and you don't change your beha your
habits and you stay ish
because two whole weeks you've been
engaged I mean come on really I mean if
you if that the danger is you go back to
ish and then you're going to be a renter
that's broke
right so yes I would do your plan
but
you know you and your wife are gonna
have to put the kids to bed and take
each other's hands and look at the other
one deeply in the eyes and say if we
don't follow this plan exactly I'm gonna
kill you I mean really I mean we have to
do this
it has to get like down in your soul
like ah
because if you if you don't this is a
really bad idea
because you're gonna get stuck in
rinterland
right yeah and we don't want that no we
don't want that uh so mathematically you
do get a better place I did what you're
doing Sharon and I did it when uh Rachel
was a kid we different reasons we sold a
home in uh up in Nashville the school
system sucked and we were driving 45
minutes one way twice a day so several
hours on the road to put kids in private
schools several thousand dollars a year
per kid and I'm like God this is nuts I
can sell this move to a different County
where the public schools are excellent
rent clear up everything and I don't
have the drive and I don't have the
private school Bill and so that's what
we did but it was part of and so
everything worked good but it's also
part of a change we lived we rented this
crappy rental for two years my wife will
still tell you stories about how much
she hated that house uh and then we were
able to buy a house but it was it was
part of a plan it wasn't a trapdoor
Escape mechanism and then I didn't deal
with the deal with
right
so you you got to promise you
your wife's got to promise you your
wife's got to promise her you gotta
promise her that that we're going to
lean in and stop the foolishness
if you go through with this I like your
plan other than that
so Rachel's right
okay so if I give you a Financial Peace
University to get you guys going will
you promise me both of you watch every
stinking lesson every minute of every
lesson and you have a conversation with
the coordinator and with the class and
you join the group in Financial Peace if
you promise me you'll do all that I'll
give it to you free
yes I do absolutely okay and you and
your wife yeah now because that if
you'll get in that group you join this
group of people to give you positive
peer pressure to not do stupid or ish
anymore
and that's that's what I'm afraid for
you because you don't have a Tracker if
you told me you've been doing this six
or eight months and you'd already paid
off thirty thousand dollars worth of
debt making eighty and you guys were on
a tight budget and you and your wife
were close-knit and unified and we were
getting after it it'd make this call
instant yep to go do what you're talking
about today and that's always the danger
with you know we even get people that
get an inheritance or that you know some
type of
large amount of money comes into their
possession and they're able which is a
blessing to be able to knock you know
the debt out but again Ryan like you
buckling down and really promising and
you guys are in a hard season with three
little kids and you know it's a lot and
so you can't allow the stress of Life
the exhaustion that you guys feel to get
you back in habit and habits that got
you here in the first place so truly
staying the course is what is going to
be it's what's going to be huge and it's
exciting right and on the flip side it's
like if that part is true then you guys
are going to be really far ahead in
these steps and you guys are gonna
you're gonna feel a lot of freedom which
is which is really great and rent the
cheapest thing you can rent that is a
bigger nicer house it's not a two one
with five people okay but don't go rent
the Taj Mahal because every dollar you
spend on rent is going to slow down your
savings
for a purchase later
so the house we rented I just explained
to you my wife was not happy with it it
was not glamorous it was the only thing
it did is meet the goal of getting our
other household and getting in the
correct County where the kids could be
in school system and uh so that that you
know and we didn't have the private
school bill and we didn't have the drive
anymore so we got quality of life we got
money back and and you know our
our rent was not that High
um even back in the day but yeah uh well
back then you know when dinosaurs roamed
the Earth you could get cheap rent but
yeah no I mean it's it's a it's a thing
it's a process that you're you're
resetting your mind and this thing and
it's just very important that you do
this right so you know getting getting
the Habit patterns that are it it you
know I made a comment about donuts
earlier and it's exactly true though on
that the the correlation with Fitness
is I mean Fitness is not a one-time
event yep it's a daily event
um of of nutrition and caloric intake
and calorie burned with exercise and
choices that you make and choices
everything controlling the person in
your mirror you know I mean it's
incremental people who are vastly
successful at their marriage didn't send
flowers one time to their wife
they every day every week do something
in their marriage it's not a singular
event you can't go be a jerk for forever
and then go on one cruise and she's
happy that's not how this works this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America if you want to know more about
what's going on around here get started
click the get started button at
ramseysolutions.com it's a free little
journey and we'll help you get lined up
and figure out what your next steps are
Ruby's in Louisiana hi Ruby welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave
um
so my husband and I we've been together
for about a decade now I'm 25 years old
so we were high school sweethearts
um I had kind of a rough childhood I
moved out whenever I was 16 years old
and a lot of the time I was financially
responsible for myself from then
um so the beginning of our relationship
um I you know I worked three jobs and he
was in school and a lot of the financial
responsibility fell on to me and I kind
of had
that control at 18 years old I bought us
a house
um you know I bought and paid off a car
but you know he drove back and forth to
learn just different things like that
I've always kind of been
um primarily the one who was responsible
for the finances how long have you been
married
okay
we we started having kids three years
ago my daughter's three and after we had
children
um I started staying home with the kids
and so of course he started working and
he makes great money now and
um you know he pays all of the bills and
he supports us financially and
I've just been I was struggling with
mental health issues and so it was hard
for me to keep that control over the
finances so I kind of just relinquish
that to him for the most part and since
then don't get me wrong we're still
financially very responsible
um we have a truck note and a mortgage
that's the only debt we have we've never
had a credit card ever we have no other
debt ever other than a vehicle and our
mortgage
um but between
you know after having kids and now I
kind of just wasn't focused on the
finances I was focused on
my children and in that meantime we kind
of took a lot from savings not just him
me as well you know he was making such
good money that we've never made before
and we really just kind of indulged
right how can we how can we best help
you today Ruby
well I guess what my question is now
that my kids are you know kind of
getting older and I've been trying to
get us back on board financially trying
to save money
um I actually read your book when I was
18 19 years old and that you know is
what I was always doing kind of going
with those plans and trying to get us
you know financially debt free and I've
it's just been a struggle between him
and I I think the Dynamics are different
um and I don't want to
emasculate him because you know I'm
finding it difficult I don't want to be
controlling like we I want a partnership
and
um it's just very hard to find a common
ground now he works in a field where in
the oil field where there's a lot of
money so Ruby I would I would say a lot
of what I'm hearing from you
is there's a lot of motivation out of
this that is pretty fear-based you don't
want to go back to how you grew up and
you're thinking oh my gosh you know what
do I need to do to protect myself
and making sure that I'm okay because I
don't want to go back there
um and in the meantime it's kind of like
you guys have just been existing you
guys don't have goals together you don't
have dreams of where you want to be as a
family together
you guys probably don't do I mean I'm
assuming a monthly budget and sit down
every month and look at the line items
and say hey here's exactly where we're
going to spend our money it just seems
like you guys are existing and again you
have you had a baby like oh I get it but
also there's just a better way to do it
and I think that's why you're calling is
because you're like how do we do this so
I think one of the most important things
is that you guys have to see each other
as a team and if you can't do that then
you guys need to ask the question why is
it because he doesn't want to he's
cautious towards you because maybe
you're controlling or maybe you're
cautious towards him because you feel
like he's irresponsible like I don't
know what the fears or the concerns or
the caution would be but if there are
those
say those out loud talk about those but
you guys need to sit down and this is
more of the Tactical side Ruby but you
guys need to sit down and say hey here
is what we need to do month to month
here is our budget together regardless
of gender husband or wife together we
sit down we both have a voice and say
hey here is where the money's going to
go and then I want you guys to sit down
Ruby and say hey in the next five years
what are our goals like what do we want
do we want this car paid off if so then
let's start attacking that and like
let's put extra money from the budget to
do that do we want to take a trip in two
years and we want to start saving
towards that do we you know like start
actually dreaming and living life
together it sounds like it's been so
separate for so long and even the
Tactical side Ruby sitting down and
doing that is gonna expose a lot of
what's going on with you guys in
marriage in the good and the bad and I
think that it just ends up becoming a
much deeper conversation when you start
with something tactical even like a
month budget so if you hold on the line
Ruby Austin's going to pick up because I
want to give you guys not only Financial
Peace University and you guys together
go through this so you guys are on the
same page but also every dollar plus and
this is our budgeting app and it's
phenomenal my husband and I literally
this morning we're had ours opened on
each of our phones and we were talking
through some stuff so like it is the
most practical thing you can do with
your money and especially if you're
married you share an account and you
guys together walk through this but but
Ruby I would really
um
I I would I would really search yourself
in a sense to figure out okay what is
going on in me that's wanting this
control where is this fear coming from
um because a lot of this is your
motivation Austin give them a copy of
Rachel's latest number one too know
yourself know your money it talks about
how you came up and how you grew up and
the parents and and how that affects
handling money so yeah Rachel Ruby
Rachel hit it exactly on the head you
were doing all the right things in the
early days with money but you were doing
them white knuckling gritting your teeth
holding your breath because of fear and
because you didn't want to go back and
that's from where you came from that's
perfectly valid but what you're figuring
out is is that there's no peace in that
there is a piece in doing the exact same
things you used to do
with your husband both of you talking
about it and being in agreement and
leaning it towards the future and you're
doing it out of a motivation of winning
rather than a fear of losing
and
um and that there's a there's a richness
to that of Soul versus I'm just never
going back there yet I mean because you
could you could become worth 10 million
dollars and not deal with the stuff
you're talking about and the only reason
you became worth 10 million dollars was
just so you didn't go back to your
childhood not a good motivation
I mean it not a good not that's not you
want more peace than that out of this
process and so sorry for what you've
been through and I'm glad that you took
away good things from it you grew up
early you grew up quick uh and you were
able at 18 to do stuff I can't get 58
year olds to do so because you were
ahead of the head of the game but now
let's not do it from a White Knuckle
anymore
let's do it from some peace and some
future goals like Rachel's talking about
there and um that's what's setting all
of this up and and where you're coming
from any little thing he does that might
look like fun or even slightly
irresponsible is magnified five thousand
times beyond what it actually is
with the lens you're looking at it with
and that's and you know that
intellectually that's why you called in
the words you're using tell us you
recognize that that you're doing that
but it's okay to just say hey the reason
I do that is
I left home at 16. hello you know I had
to buy food and you're not going to
demasculate him no by speaking the truth
and being involved either so step into
that and be confident in what in what
you're thinking and feeling and all of
it and you guys together see yourselves
like locked arms and out there is the
money issues right there it's not in
between you guys you're you're not each
other's enemy the money issues are the
enemies so let's attack that instead of
each other I think you're pretty cool
Ruby I think you're going to win
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Rachel Cruz number
one best-selling author co-host of the
smart money happy hour Ramsey
personality and my daughter is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Shane starts this hour in Baltimore hi
Shane welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
all right so I feel like I know the
answer to this question which I hate but
I wanted to hear from you
um so I recently purchased a home from
my grandmother who passed
um and I knew it was essentially a steal
to buy because I was going to get it way
lower than it's actually valued at so
long story short I have equity in the
home which is awesome but I've been
struggling internally to figure out if I
should roll my credit card debt into
that home into the equity of the home
and then pay that off with gazelle
intensity
um I have twenty six thousand dollars in
debt credit card debt um and
I make 85 a year so you're single
I'm single what's the answer to your
question you know it
I know what it is I just but it would
free up 400 a month for me if I were to
roll it but I it's funny I tell my mom
like my problem is not the debt my
problem is that I'm not disciplined
enough
to knock it out like why do I need to
consolidate it into my into my equity
so
and that answer is what Shane
uh that
I mean I feel like I'm getting to a
point where
I really the answer is that I shouldn't
do it I know I know exactly what I
should do I just I wanted to make sure
it was the right thing to do the thing
is let's kind of back up for a second
okay 400 a month is not true
okay that's forty eight hundred dollars
a year you're not saving that on twenty
seven thousand dollars worth of debt in
interest the only way you're saving 400
a month is if you're going to be in debt
longer
gotcha which is absolutely not your goal
no it's not okay so you're just trying
to dumb this down to make it easy and
it's not going to get easy the you know
it this is Band-Aid fast off
versus
Band-Aid slow off and your get gangrene
true that gross
[Laughter]
hey Shane and I are okay Rachel you
don't have to worry about it if you
don't want in it's okay so I'm like
Google Imaging
here's the deal yeah get fired up and
lay it out lay out the math and go what
is it you make Again by the way
85 Okay so 27. so you're by yourself you
don't have to talk anybody into this
you're how old
29. okay one year
you really think I can do it in one year
I'm positive you can do it one year
I knew you were gonna say this and
here's the problem Shane you have no
life
for a whole year all you're going to do
is work and eat ramen noodles and pay
debt no going out no eating out no
vacation work work work work work work
and you're done in a year see this is
only about twenty three hundred dollars
a month
and you're done in one year
what is the debt the 26 I mean it's
credit card debit what was it just on
was it just life was it it's life over
about eight years that's what's gonna be
hard Shane is it's not like this is just
a car loan and you made one purchase
that puts you in this these are multiple
decisions you know what I mean over life
and you're and you're used to living
that kind of lifestyle of twenty six
thousand dollars above
what you've been making so it's gonna
feel even more sacrificial in a sense uh
so just as as a heads up here's the
thing if you'll do this it'll make you a
multi-millionaire and here's why it'll
make you a multi-millionaire here's why
because
the anytime you get ready to be chaotic
and sloppy and disorganized and slip
back into credit card debt you will
remember the year from hell and you will
not let yourself do it
dang but if you wander your butt just
kind of lollygagging along out of debt
you will wander back in
because you but if you have to pay a
price I mean if you got the the year
from hell in your Consciousness and you
go crap no I'm not buying that there's
no way now I'm not going on a month
without a budget I remember where that
put me before wow and you this is this
is it's settled in your brain it's
settled in your body and settled in your
spirit and that's why I'm telling you to
do it it's not just because it gets you
out of debt and it's not just because
it's absolutely the highest probability
you will win but what we're doing here
is we're resetting the way you handle
money for the rest of your life yep
and that's going to make you it's going
to make you're only 27 29 gonna make it
10 million dollars I mean I promise you
the math says it because you know how to
make money and you've not been horrible
with money I mean you're not like as bad
as like Congress or something I mean
you're not you know you're not you're
not you know you only got twenty seven
thousand dollars but it's just sloppy
it's like the the enemy of pretty it's
pretty intense not it's not just shame
shame but like twenty six thousand
dollars in credit card debt from just
life though like it's gonna be a shift
chain like you got to hear that but it
needs to happen it wasn't like a this
explosion of stupidity it was gradual
you know like you said that's that's the
truth and and so the the danger of that
is is the enemy of Excellence is not
horrible the enemy of Excellence is okay
complacency yep it's oh this is good
enough
you know and we used to say this redneck
saying I don't know if they say this
kind of stuff anymore close enough for
government work have you ever heard that
one close enough for government work
nope which means half butt do your job
okay that's what it means in the
neighborhood I grew up in and so you
know it's mediocrity yeah you know and
so and and you know Shane you're
fighting what all of America is fighting
the this slip into mediocrity and you've
got the ability here to completely
change that and the cool thing is you
already knew every bit of it before you
called here and now all you got to do is
go do it I'm proud of you man proud of
you great shame I can't wait to do your
debt-free scream with you in a year when
you hate the Old Shane so bad that you
will never go back to him and you were
breaking up with him never going back
with him and so we're going to be
organized diligent have money budgeted
for fun money budgeted for luxuries and
we're going to go become very wealthy
and outrageously generous and that's in
your future you could be a millionaire
in 10 years
you really can be from where you're
sitting right now you're in really
because mainly because of headspace your
head space is excellent as long as the
gangrene doesn't get them
rip that Band-Aid off Shane
so gross watch out for the amputation
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that wins has a good offense and a good
defense money's the same way
offenses you get out of debt you invest
and you're generous defense is insurance
you need good insurance you need to
protect your finances from the big
emergencies there's 10 kinds of
insurance coverage you might need based
on what your life looks like today
and we built a tool called the coverage
checkup which shows you the types you
need to add
the junk you need to drop and the
adjustments you need to make and we'll
even rank your coverage list by
importance email it to you and connect
you to a Ramsey trusted insurance
provider to help you get this new plan
in place fast none of it costs you a
dime
matter of fact you're probably going to
save some money as a result go to
ramseysolutions.com checkup completely
free
ramsesolutions.com checkup do not let
emergencies sneak up on you Russ is with
us in South Bend hi Russ welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi thanks so much uh Dave we
are a young married couple in our early
70s and we have we're financially free
and at this stage of Life we've got
about 80 000 in cash uh we've gone
through Financial Peace University and
uh designated uh the emergency fund out
of that but my question is twofold
um what's the best thing to do with that
money obviously sitting in the bank is
probably not the best thing to do the
second question is is the goal of wealth
realistic at this stage in our lives
uh we have to Define wealth uh extreme
wealth unless you make really really
good money no because time is not on
your side
um but uh but can we you know can we
build a nice Nest Egg a plump one sure
and of course that depends on a whole a
whole host of other factors and
variables that you
can control some of and some of you can
affect but yeah
um so
but I mean sixty thousand invested in
good mutual funds if it averages 10
percent would double every seven years
so it'd be if you don't add anything to
it so it would be you know and you know
if you're 70 it would when you're 77 it
would be 120 and if you're
um 84 it'd be 240.
give or take but I mean that's pretty
close
and that's if you don't anything to it
now of course you've got income you've
got other things going on but you know a
quarter million dollars uh as a plump
little nest egg in your early 80s is
certainly better than a whole host of
people
absolutely and you know neighborhood I
grew up in we called that rich but it's
probably not really rich but yeah
no that's that's great so mutual funds
would be the way to go in your opinion
if you're going to leave your hands off
of it yeah if you can leave your hands
off of it you have an emergency fund in
addition and uh you have income to live
on
we both uh we pull in about 60 Grand a
year about 30 a piece uh at this stage
I've got a financial stream from my old
Insurance business I live on residuals
and uh occasional referrals uh she also
is on Social Security and uh she's
working at an accounting firm and she
does a little part-time work for that so
this is semi retirement for us and there
is a street income streams for both of
us along that that amount of money
good perfect excellent well done yeah I
mean so you're secure and uh and so we
can allow this money to grow we might
even be able to add a little bit to it
as we go along uh if you wanted to
there's there's no no Panic here it's
not like the the house is on fire but
you've done it I mean you set yourself
up to where you should be able to
prosper with that it's great for us yeah
absolutely Ashley's with us Ashley's in
Los Angeles hi Ashley how are you how
six
um we have about 450 000 left on our
mortgage of just under a million dollars
in equity and my husband would like to
take about the about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars that we have in our
savings possibly invest that in in real
estate and in Investments and so my and
my opinion is that we should we're 450
000 to completely being debt free that
we could should continue to chip away at
that mortgage payment rather than invest
now
um so we just aren't sure where to go
from here
yeah it's a good question Ashley I mean
it's one that I feel like a lot of
people are asking these days this comes
up a lot
um that I see so yeah I'm more of your
line of thinking I would throw that
money at the at your primary home pay it
off and then make it a goal for you guys
to to buy an investment property which
may be tough in Los Angeles to do it
with cash but that's how we recommend
doing it right how much do you guys make
a year
so combined income is just about 225
000. okay
and he go ahead well what do you guys do
for a living
so I'm in real estate so that's why I
love taking those commission checks and
throwing them at our mortgage
um and just pretty much living off of
his income which he's in law enforcement
what does he make of the 250.
um about
150 to 1
100 a year at this plus the 150 you're
done in three years
okay how old are y'all
38. so you're a whole 41 years old uh
you own a house at that point that's
worth a million and a half to two
million dollars
and um it's completely paid for and you
make 250 000 a year that sets you up to
build a lot of wealth in the future
um and if you go put 150 000 down on a
six or seven hundred thousand dollar
rental property it'll barely cash flow
barely cash flow right and so there's no
blessing there
so it's so the answer to the question is
not real estate or what can you do or
that the answer is should the lens to
look at it is okay what gets us when
we're 50 to the highest net worth
which method which method and I can
promise you the method that does that is
paying off your mortgage first and then
paying cash for your first rental
property and you can do all of that
before you're 50.
mm-hmm yeah because there's there's
still this myth out there Ashley with
real estate and investment real estate I
see it everywhere it's just like I I
just it feels higher than it has in a
long time of people wanting to get in
and do stuff and because there's kind of
this mentality of like oh my gosh how
great it's kind of fun and like we have
this other property and we get rental
income and it feels like this cool thing
to do but in reality it's a it's a side
business I mean you're going to be
dealing with tenants and on top of that
the money never ends up being what
people think it is with the headache and
everything like what what you guys end
up after fixing stuff in the house
paying the mortgage because you're
taking mortgage out on it if the rent
isn't paid I mean there's just so much
that goes into it that's not as
glamorous as it seems and it's great we
love real estate we are a real estate
family my husband does Real Estate
dad Dave loves real estate so it's not
that we're against it in fact it's a
wonderful thing but you want to do it
the right way because if you go in about
if you go if you go into it like you
guys are thinking it's it doesn't end up
being as wonderful and great as an
Instagram reel makes it out to be that
you see all the time yeah for real
nothing ends up as great as an Instagram
in reality so uh but yeah the the
you know you're dealing folks with a
someone who doesn't know anything about
real estate when they say things like
well the tenant will pay the bill
that means you've never had a tenant
that's what that means that means you've
never had a hot water heater go out the
same month that the tenant moved out and
broke the contract
and you don't even know where they are
they just left
oh and this was in a nice house not a
junky house
and they trashed it
the same month so I'm putting in heat
and air I'm having to paint it because
there's more on spray painted the wall
for some reason they decided to do this
as they broke the contract and left and
disappeared in the middle of the night
and I got no payment coming in I got a
lot of money going out
this is landlording
this is landlording right here now can
you make money net net of all of that
yeah because you put a tenant back in
you're going to get rent and you don't
have any payments if you don't need
payments but if you put down 150 000
Los Angeles you're hiney under the thing
I just described you'll look back there
and it's gone this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions at triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
don't wait until the AC or something
else goes out neighborly helps you find
local providers like airserv Mr
Appliance dryer vent Wizard and
Precision Door Service go to
neighborly.com great company they'll
help you out yeah so today's question
comes from Jeremy in Pennsylvania I am
doing a will I'm 55 years old and have a
wife and two adult children I'm split
between leaving everything to my wife or
going ahead and leaving things to my
kids as well there are certain things I
want my kids to have but I don't want my
wife to think that I don't trust her to
carry out my wishes if I proceed her
uh is it weird not to leave everything
to my wife
um
necessarily it is her money too though I
mean like it's not just your money and
your stuff it's you guys together but I
think if you were to say hey when I you
know if I pass away
what would you how much you know what
does it look like for your life you know
this is you talking to your wife of what
do things look like for you what um what
will you have will you be taken care of
making sure she's your priority first
because your adult children
or second in that and then if everything
is fine and good like I'm okay with you
saying okay you know do we want to get
leave them
you know x amount in X amounts but all
of that is communicated with her because
this is her money too that's what I
would say there's two things built into
your question that are disturbing the
way you State this is almost like
there's a possibility this is your
second wife and these kids aren't hers
and if that's the case then
um you know then you've got to have this
discussion and go I am going to leave
you this amount to take care of you and
this amount for them because I want to
do that if that's the case if not the
other thing that may be hidden in here
is there's like some reason that you
feel like she's not going to do this
like she's been irresponsible or you all
haven't been unified in your decision
making on money and so you have a reason
to kind of worry that she's not going to
follow through on your wishes
um if that's the case then that's
another issue that's different than a
will that's a marriage issue a trust
issue that you've got to get into yeah
for sure yeah and so
um that that's two possibilities I mean
the third possibility is as simple as
um these are her kids her kids and um
you can do whatever you want to do with
your money but it's also hers as Rachel
stated so we ought to talk about this
and just figure it out together what's
you know what is your motivation on that
and primary is that she's taken care of
if you don't leave her enough to have a
wonderful life because you gave too much
to your kids yeah you've grown kids
strange that wouldn't I would not agree
with that yeah uh your your primary
responsibility is to her okay so what I
just thought of this question is we are
talking this out if you did have a
second marriage
and all grown kids or even tea I mean
maybe even well I'd say grown kids yeah
what is the what is the responsibility
if someone is bringing in money to a
marriage
and they are one now yeah but she has
four adult kids and he has two and it
they're later in life you know what I
mean like does he have responsibility to
leave money to those four kids or it's
going to be left to her so she's
probably gonna you know what I mean like
gets really complicated yeah because uh
you know second marriage could be 25
years long
you know it could be longer than the
first yep and
um wouldn't be that unusual uh and so uh
and you know the grown kids are all okay
and he wants first to make sure his new
wife is taken care of that wouldn't be
bad yeah wouldn't be bad sure so you
just got to think that through but
there's no inherent
entitlement
that these grown kids are in tight adult
children are entitled uh morally
ethically spiritually none of that
um and
um it's It's Not Unusual in the in a
situation with a stepmom as an example
uh for the adult kids to resent her
getting anything
uh and that's a sense of entitlement
yeah that is wrong yeah that sense of
entitlement is wrong but uh so like I've
got a a wealthy friend who's in his 70s
I got remarried uh and um recently and I
don't know what his estate plan is but
his kids are perfectly his grown kids
are perfectly functional yep they don't
need anything yep uh so you know where I
in his situation I will make sure she's
taken care of and I want to leave some
to them yep uh but uh and he's got the
the you know the ability to do both in
that case so but what's primary I I
think your spouse is probably gonna be
primary even then yeah uh if you had to
look do you think the step kids are
entitled to yeah not necessarily not
yeah I mean that's almost prenup stuff
yeah yeah uh but it's it's it's the
complications of Yours Mine and Ours and
uh it requires even that much more uh
constant communication and discussion
about the estate plan you know so like
your brother and your husband are in a
state planning meeting with me and your
mom tomorrow you know and Winston is you
know is not in my bloodline but he's
married to you and uh handles a lot of
our real estate and so yeah we're going
to be there tomorrow talking through you
know some changes what we're doing but
you know what's that look like and
everybody's got to be in it you know
everybody's got to know what's going on
I'm getting cut out of the wheel Dave uh
no I'm getting cut out of the wheel
really you know changes it's so freaking
complicated we have to review it every
so often yeah no totally to make sure we
remember what we said we were doing and
I think it's that's another piece to
this too that I think is important
another element is as an adult child
right as we all are but
that's why doing this in your 20s your
30s or 40s is setting your own family up
right regardless of where your parents
depend upon your parents or any
messiness that comes out of wills and
all of this like that you are in a
position that you're taking care of
yourself yeah and that and then that's
just gravy yes yes gravy on the biscuit
that's exactly right and then the second
thing that comes out of another point
that comes out of this discussion is hey
you need a will yes everybody does and
78 of Americans die without oil stupid
it's just stupid get your will done go
to Mama legal mama bearlegalforms.com
get your will done the second thing is
tell everybody what's going to happen
like if you've got
step children we're talking about her
kids and she did not bring wealth into
the marriage or she did and they're
going to get hers but they're not going
to get yours tell them yep tell them so
you know or or tell them I'm gonna take
tell your kids I'm going to take care of
my new wife with this and whatever's
left over you're gonna get and so they
don't go wow I'm dead
go ahead and get all that out of the way
you know let's just tell everybody where
it is go ahead and have a reading of the
will and if somebody's gonna be pissed
off let them do it while you're alive
yep you know and another question we get
all the time is how do I help my parents
talk about this stuff how do I I get my
parents to do a will how do I start
these kind of conversations because of
importance so if that if you are in that
situation that wasn't one of my FPU
classes that I when I coordinated it
we're done now but one of the questions
that came through two weeks ago yeah it
was a lady that um she said that she was
like I my husband's parents told him
that he's going to have to be the
executor of everything but he didn't
know what's in it and he didn't you know
and so I'm like sitting down and saying
hey we want we want this communicated
really clearly so that your wishes are
granted and your legacy how you want it
is to be you know to be honest I refuse
to be the executor or something and I
don't know what it is yeah
that's asinine it's a secret but we want
you to be in charge of the secret
no not a chance not signing up for your
toxic BS no thank you and that's exactly
what was going on yeah so no we're not
doing that we're going to sit down
everybody's gonna know we're all going
to talk about it and then I can actually
I don't care if I get any money I'm not
after the money I just want to help you
execute your wishes that's what the
executor does is execute your wishes
secrets and your toxic BS not a chance
not doing that there's a great line at
the end of a Taylor Swift song It's a
hero what's the line
she says I had a dream well I don't know
if you have time to quote the whole
thing but she yes she had a dream that
uh her stepdaughter married for the
money and then found out she wasn't in
the will and they all said she's looking
up from us
I can't even you didn't you can't finish
him for laughing this is the Ramsey Show
so good
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
retro Cruz Ramsey personality
Taylor Swift song quota too today you
giggled all the way through it I had a
dream my daughter-in-law kills me for
the money she thinks I left them in the
will is it and then they all have the
reading and they realize you know
they're not in it and then the last line
is they're all screaming she's laughing
up at us from hell can I say that yes oh
I guess
we don't get fined for help I don't know
I mean as far as I know yeah all right
remember when you thought asinine was a
cuss word
there's that Michelle is in Rochester
New York hey Michelle how are you
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
um so my husband and I are trying to
decide if we should move in with our
mother-in-law we are going to be seniors
in college we've been married two years
now
and there's two main reasons why we
would move the first is we would save
money probably we'd still pay her rent
but we'd probably save 400 a month
and the second reason is because she's a
single mom and her son is moving out to
get married so now she'll be in the
house alone and she doesn't like to be
alone
yes her son your husband
my husband's twin brother oh okay
yeah so Michelle a reason to move in
with an in-law
under the
um motivation because she doesn't like
to be alone that starts to really
entangle a relationship
because
it sounds
like you're being kind but it actually
ends up being extremely dysfunctional
that she's depending it upon you guys
it's the only way she's not alone is her
grown children stay home with her that's
dysfunctional I'll just say it that way
yeah okay I'm sorry this lady it's a
normal thing to cry when your grown kids
leave and cheer 20 minutes later it's a
normal thing to do that you do both okay
and uh to just cry and I don't wanna she
needs to have a life outside of her
children
okay I will say um she is very
self-sufficient she still works no she's
not not emotionally
um
it's not that she I mean it was just
sort of an idea that was brought up and
we would only live with her for a year
and she knows that and
um she also like
I don't know
it's it's I guess in the situation it's
hard to inscribe but I'm not as much
concerned about her like if because
we've talked about not moving in and she
would just go on with life
yeah I think it's going to be better for
y'all and her emotionally and
relationally but that's not a
psychologist or a therapist speaking or
a pastor speaking that's just an old man
telling you
okay you do whatever you want to do and
do you guys is there a reason you know
you said You're Gonna Save four hundred
dollars but there are juniors in college
you said right
uh we'll be seniors here coming up the
twin brother and his new wife aren't
staying
uh
um
so they sort of had their own situation
um we had just talked about it like
because it was our last year of college
it might be nice to save money and take
some of the strain off of ourselves
yeah if you want to do it it's fine and
it's the way you presented it sounded
weird
okay
so that our answer changes or my I'll
say my answer is more cautious for you
Michelle
because of the end of that it's not that
we're doing this for a financial goal
because some people do that right I mean
we we talk to people a lot that they're
like hey we're gonna make this move uh
because we have this goal and then we're
gonna be out there's a date it's very
specific all of that I'm not completely
against that it was the last part when
you said and because she doesn't like to
be alone that's where my flag went up
just for you Michelle like woman to
woman no it goes up for her it goes up
for your husband too yeah that's what's
weird I mean that is weird so if that
part wasn't the end of it though and if
your only question was hey
is our last year of college
and we're able to save some money if we
do this you know what do you guys think
about that if that was it
I would say and you're all in yeah and I
would say I mean yeah if that's what you
guys choose to do and but I would have
an end date I would not be living with
my in-laws over in a long extended
period of time as young newlyweds I
don't think that I think you guys
figuring out life just you guys together
is really healthy
um I would prefer that you didn't I
think you guys just figuring out life
together is is great
um but if you wanted to and had an end
date and all of that you it could be an
option it won't like
destroy but it's that into that other
part of the question that I'm like oh
just don't you know what I heard was
just codependence and I don't I wouldn't
I don't recommend that for anybody
um you know if uh because there's not an
end there's not an end of that that
needy that neediness is not something
that needs to be fed it needs to be
healed
and that's that's all I was saying just
from again that's just old man talking
so it's not there's no professional
quote guidance there you you called us
and ask our opinion so and I don't think
she's a bad lady I think she's just
normal it's normal she's got two twin
boys they're the last two to leave yeah
and uh and she's a single mom and they
they've been her world and that's a
normal grieving of that yes but it's
also a release
that and you know she doesn't have a
choice she's got to move on with the
next chapter of her life and you guys
can't run over there every time she's
lonely yep um that's that's uh yeah okay
anyway I'll shut our piece be careful be
careful be careful Janice is with us
Janice is in Charlotte North Carolina hi
Janice how are you
why what are you scared of
well um
I have no retirement
um I'm still working
um made some very poor decisions with
the money ever though my life
um
uh ranged up in a Christian home but the
only
scripture I remember about money was the
one that says Don't store up for
yourselves
um things that would you know
be poor yeah yeah I got you I remember
that script yeah and I never I never
really learned money management for my
parents day one four and uh before I run
tight on time how can we help you hun
well I just I've got three hundred
dollars in my emergency phone so far and
I want to get started I just what do you
mean I'm afraid I don't what do I make
uh I bring home about 3 000 a month good
all right and you have no and you have
no money how much debt do you have
uh I have a twenty thousand dollar car
um I have uh ten thousand dollar credit
card uh four thousand dollar credit card
uh twelve hundred dollar credit card and
a three thousand dollar personal loan at
the bank yeah well there's a reasonable
reasons to be scared not terrorized but
scared because this is an unhealthy
situation and you're and you're
recognizing I have to address it
um and so I would let that if fear tells
me to not touch a hot stove or get out
of the road a car's coming that's good
fear
yeah and it's I don't want it to be
debilitating fear fear that keeps you up
at night causes you have to take anxiety
medicine that's not what I'm talking
about but I mean if fear tells you to
get out of the road you're getting ready
to get hit by a car that's good fear so
and that's kind of where you are you got
a mess and you're going I gotta deal
with this so what we'll do is we'll help
you okay we'll walk with you uh it's not
going to be easy you're going to get
your income up you're probably going to
sell this car and you're going to do
some difficult things but we'll show you
how in Financial Peace University it's
our nine-week class uh you'll have
people around you that are holding you
accountable and encouraging you uh
because you're scared and you need some
encouragement and uh and a gift that to
you Janice so stay on the line oh yeah
we're not gonna charge you for it thank
you pick up and do that for you be
completely free for you yeah and the
thing is this be afraid enough to do
something but not so afraid that you're
that you're Frozen
so get out of the road don't freeze in
the headlights and we'll walk you out of
the road and get you to the sidewalk and
then walk you to Uptown so um and the
good thing about this Sue Janice is that
there's gonna be a lot of quick progress
in this that you're going to see and
because of all these these debts there's
a lot of them so it feels overwhelming
even as you listed it but you're going
to start with the debt snowball you're
gonna start knocking this stuff out
and it's gonna take some years you know
it's it's a marathon it's not a Sprint
But continuing to make those decisions
day in and day out you're going to see
progress Janice you really will probably
for the first time in your life actually
get traction the right way mm-hmm hold
on we'll help you
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show
where we help people
build wealth the work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality my
daughter number one best-selling author
and co-host of smart money happy hour on
Ramsay networks a very popular fun and
funny podcast with George Campbell is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Nicholas is in St Louis hi Nicholas how
are you
I'm doing good you better than I deserve
what's up thank you hi yes um I just
wanted to call in
um so I wanted to get your opinion on a
question I had
um as she's a stay-at-home mother I work
out of the house I make about 50 000 a
year
um we have about eleven thousand dollars
in car loan debt about nine thousand
dollars in other debt like credit cards
um and we have a baby he's eight months
old and we have another baby on the way
when are you getting married
um at the beginning of next year yeah
2024.
um
yesterday
I think we're just nervous with the like
the insurance because right now she's
getting Insurance
um a separate insurance than I am and
we're just kind of nervous there with uh
how much it might cost us if she goes on
our insurance don't be nervous go find
out
yeah we haven't asked a whole lot of
questions in regards to that yeah yeah
we need to do that well you you okay go
ahead how can we help okay yeah yeah so
we're currently rinsing from her um from
her grandmother
um and we started to look at some
apartments
um locally today um the past couple
weeks actually and whenever her
grandmother found out about this
um she offered us the house that we're
currently living in it's worth 250 000
for 150
000 so she's offering it to us for a
hundred thousand dollars less than the
market value and I'm just curious um if
we should take that offer and what would
be the best approach to that
no
you should not buy houses with people
that you're not married to
I know under any circumstances
this would be like later on
on middle of next year I would say why
yeah
[Music]
okay so here here's what I would do okay
yeah
um in terms of the structure of that
deal I would offer to rent it from her
for three years
with an option to purchase it for a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in writing
in writing in writing so if she dies
your crazy uncle doesn't try to undo the
deal
that makes sense how did I know you had
a crazy uncle but anyway yeah so um but
the uh you see what I'm saying so yeah
in writing and then you go get married
get yourself out of debt get an
emergency fund in place
go check the insurance this week
quit using that as an excuse
with a baby on the way
okay and let's find out what's going on
I want you to be responsible and and and
if the insurance gives you really crazy
news and you stick with your plan fine
but
um but you need to be act you need to be
making major life decisions from Facts
not feelings
that makes sense so go go get the facts
decide when we're getting married sooner
rather than later is better for the kids
for the finances for everything then we
lean in knock out the debt build an
emergency fund build a down payment and
then we execute on the option meaning we
go ahead and purchase this wonderful
deal
I assume you're the soon to be wife
wants to live in this house
yes yeah this has been her uh dream for
a long time it's her grandmother is that
right yeah Nicholas yeah it's her
grandmother in this house so it's not
you're crazy uncle yeah okay all right
so yeah in writing and if you want to
get real thorough you would record the
option at the courthouse
okay which keeps title from being
transferred
okay because you now have a cloud on the
title they have to talk to you first
that's a very that's a very thorough way
uh I don't know if I'd go quite that far
but it's not the end of the world to do
that that would be a very professional
uh business way to to transact this yep
but yeah don't close on this house while
you're broke single engaged kids that's
what I was gonna say just make sure you
do this in order Nicholas you guys
you're getting married paying off debt
pay off your own debt in the process as
of now uh work on that and then once you
guys have savings you're married
everything then yep purchase the home I
think it's great and
man I would um
it makes things a lot less complicated
in many regards
if you guys know you're together if you
know that she's the one yeah to get
married and obviously she's expecting so
you don't want to I understand not
wanting to mess with insurance but um
yeah be looking aside from necklace this
is just interesting and it's good for me
to point this out Dr John deloney and I
were talking about this on the air the
other day here on this show uh now today
more people live together that aren't
married that aren't married
in America and so that we've had this
demographic shift
on this issue Professor Bill galston
President Clinton's domestic policy
advisor a senior fellow at Brooking
Brookings Institute explained the
interesting poverty statistics
if you graduate from high school marry
before having a child and have a child
after age 20 only eight percent of the
people who do those three things will
end up being poor while 79 percent who
fail to do those three things end up
being poor
statistically
wow
same thing
uh 97 percent of Millennials who follow
the success sequence different piece of
research
here's the success sequence first earn
at least a high school diploma two get a
job and work three get married before
having children will not be poor as they
enter their mid-30s 97 percent of the
people who follow that will not be poor
as they enter into their mid-30s and so
the success sequence doing things in
order you said right that's what popped
this Research into my mind
um it's it's very it sounds like it's
old-fashioned values or moralistic Bible
thumping or something like that but
there's data that says that people that
don't do things in the right order have
a bigger struggle yeah 97 of those who
follow the success sequence will not be
in poverty in their 30s
wow let me tell you what it was again at
least a high school diploma get a job
marry before having kids that's the
success sequence the other piece was
Mary before having a child graduate from
high school and have a child after age
20 only eight percent of the people do
who do so will be poor 79 percent who
fail to do those three will be poor
eight out of ten
so I mean you know so coach yourself up
coach your kids up coach your niece and
nephew up whatever it is this stuff
matters because it has consequences all
through these are not Standalone
compartmentalized decisions they affect
your money they affect your career they
affect your health they affect
everything there's a reason for this
stuff this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions in level their operations to
learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today and uh one of our favorite
people in the world dropped by to hang
out for a couple of segments Dr Meg
Meeker author of the book strong fathers
strong daughters is where I met you many
many years ago uh that book was a huge
best seller and we told all of America
about it made sure it continued to be a
huge bestseller because I just love the
concept of how important dads are in a
culture where dads are not respected
anymore and it's getting weirder and
weirder and all this kind of stuff so
she's going to hang out with us here uh
all kinds of fun stuff going on in the
whole fatherhood space isn't there Meg
well there is and a lot of things are
changing and shifting and that's why I'm
really gearing up I'm serious now about
helping dads because no one else is
doing it and I really believe we're
coming into what I call the new era of
fatherhood and I'm writing about that
we've had a convergence of three things
dads have been gutted it and I'm I'm
done with that
um you know depression and anxiety in
kids is skyrocketing and I see that and
then finally kids are getting bombarded
with insane messages and they're being
hurt they're so confused even the
Surgeon General finally came out and
said oh guess what people's social media
is bad for kids and yeah who knew and so
I'm a strong believer that dads are the
answer to so many of these things but
they don't know it so when you say for
somebody just we've got a huge segment
of our audience that's brand new in the
last few months uh when you say
fatherhood or dads have been gutted
there's your first point talk about what
you mean by that oh sure
um you know and I have seen it you
probably have too with the rise of
feminism you know we said women are
important push men aside and then we
said women can do it all push them
farther aside and then we finally got to
a point it's like we don't even need
dads to have children you know we've
sort of pushed them away we have taught
dads they're not necessary we've taught
them that we don't need them financially
we've taught them that moms can meet all
of their kids needs
um and now what we've seen is fathers
have left and now we're seeing men in
general just being bashed to pieces you
know if I hear you know white supremacy
and all this you know
anti-masculine talk
um and men feel it and and know it and I
think it's really time to say enough is
enough because what I see in kids is I
see the way kids see their dads
and if dads could see themselves the way
their kids see them they'd realize that
kids look at their dads and see pure
gold in there and they want it and dads
have no idea hmm
that's powerful because they do they
play such a role as a mom I play you
know I have a voice in my kids life
that's different than Winston's and
Winston has a voice in our kid's life
that is different so talk talk about you
know what is that for for a dad that
feels like oh my gosh you know I'm
working 70 hours a week I'm exhausted my
kids are in two sports we're running
we're gunning we're doing this life
[Music]
um just so the average Dad out there
like what kind of encouragement when you
say when you say like your kids when
they look at their dads they see gold
um you know what incur what are things
that are just like tactically that
you're like yeah the average Dad out
there that's that's do in life and
trying to be great right like I mean
like that there's not working really
hard yeah and everybody's telling them
they're not yeah exactly everyone's
telling them they're not you know doing
a good job well I work with a lot of you
know um intense men high power driven
and what I tell them about is they're
basically three kids three things your
kids need affection attention and
affirmation and acceptance as well
um but but they need touchdown moments
they don't need to spend long chunks of
time with their kids but focusing on
their kids and giving them attention
here and there bedtime you walk in a
room put your phone down you know how
much more attention you could give your
kids you just put your phone down spend
a lot of time on emails and when you see
your kids touch them hug them look at
them in the face
um and you know and when you see them do
something great character when you see a
good character affirm that and so you
can fit all of these things in and
around a very busy schedule and and get
your kids to where you want them to be
so what is a gate what's the best way
when it comes to engaging your kids how
much do you lean on I'm getting really
tactical here Meg but like how much do
you lean on like actually physically
playing how much of it is sitting down
and being like I just want to hear how
you are exactly and emotionally
attaching to your kids because I feel
like that that's a real big part that's
something even Winston I talk about a
lot with our three little ones is like
Winston is he's such a great dad but
he's like and he's like I just want to
know I want to know who they are where
they're at and talk to them talk to them
and they will tell you stuff you know
what I mean even at eight five years old
like they will talk so how important is
the Run and Gun the fun and also balance
with like I actually want to know what's
going on inside of you and where you're
at and and be there with you yeah well
first of all it depends on the age of a
child an eight-year-old can't look at
you and tell you how they feel they just
they can't articulate and they don't
even know how they feel
um but this is something you could do
you're sitting in the kitchen you're
doing I'm sorry your child's sitting in
the kitchen doing their homework you're
in the living room and you say hey come
here just for 10 minutes take a break I
just haven't talked to you all week how
are things just ask them some simple
questions let them answer don't say a
word and then they'll go back to what
they're doing let your kids know you
like their company and they'll talk if
you're going on a Saturday morning to
change the oil in your car ask them to
go along
um if you know if you go to the grocery
store ask them to just come and just say
I I just want to talk to you and it's in
those moments that you hear from them
and you figure out what they're thinking
and feeling so is the antithesis of that
what has caused this rates of depression
and anxiety to Skyrocket yes let's
disconnect disconnect and here's what's
happening it's you know it's kind of
like a perfect storm
families are living as autonomous beings
under the same roof kids live in a very
separate World from their parents they
do things on the internet social media
their parents have no idea about their
parents are on their screens doing their
things and there's really no connection
there because kids have learned to
interact with people socially very
differently than you and I did
and the way they've been taught to
interact is not real it's not satisfying
they're lonely and that's why depression
is going up because there's no sitting
down talking with Dad looking him in the
eye having dinner and saying you know
how's that buddy of yours at school that
was doing so badly talk to me about that
yeah so net net Facebook friends aren't
real friends no
no no no no no Dr mcmeeker is our guest
this hour she's been a frequent
appearance on the uh smart conference
with us over the years New York Times
bestseller many times over strong Father
Strong daughters was one of those
currently the new era of fatherhood
video course is available now at
meekerparenting.com Meeker
m-e-e-k-e-r
parenting.com you can also check out
live coaching calls with for dads there
and on June 22nd there's a free live
coaching webinar talk about that oh
that's gonna be fun
um it's it's talks about how your
childhood affects your being a dad
oh yeah yeah you say oh yeah but it's
absolutely true because what you learned
as a kid what you experienced as a boy
or didn't or didn't exactly carries into
how you parent in a way it drives your
parenting but dads don't know that you
know if they had a bad relationship with
Mom they have a hard time being close to
their daughters showing affection and
they know they want to but they don't
know why they want to a lot of things
they want to do in parenting and they
don't know why they can't so let's
rewind a little bit so I'm going to be
talking about that I'm going to be
taking calls and I'm really excited
about the live coaching that I'm going
to be doing
um for dads on an ongoing basis to
groups so good yeah and and that's what
I love I love you know being on Zoom
calls with dads and just answering
questions can you stay one more segment
yeah all right let's keep talking about
this I want to hear about this uh four
things any father can do to make
dramatic changes in their child's life
from probably the world's leading expert
on that subject sitting here with us you
don't want to miss this this is real
stuff right here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
to make your own medical decisions is a
big deal these days Christian Healthcare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership-based
non-profit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so cfchm could be right for your
family check out more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr Meg Meeker the website is
meekerparenting.com author of the book
strong fathers strong daughters talking
about how dad's presence and Dad's
engagement all the things that it does
uh the fatherhood crisis that we have
can be tied to a lot of societal
crisises as well in America and it's not
just a physical absence and not just a
divorce it's not that it's this
devaluing of the position of fatherhood
that you've been so concerned about over
the whole years that we've known you I
mean you and I've been doing this
together like 20 years I think now and
so uh live coaching calls with dads at
meekerparenting.com available June 22nd
just a few days away there'll be a free
one week away there'll be a free live
coaching webinar how to experience how
your experiences as a son drive your
parenting as a dad
parenting.com the new era of fatherhood
video course available now
pick up that book and uh the latest
version of that you did was hero dead so
it's called and you wrote the
introduction yeah yeah and uh oh I did
write the intro yeah or the forward or
whatever you call it yeah yeah I don't
know what you call it there yeah because
I I just uh
from the very first time I read strong
fathers and that's got to be 20 years
ago
um my daughters were already grown but I
started recognizing immediately uh what
you were saying there that the
statistics of a Confident Woman being
associated with having a strong
relationship with her dad a competent
won't grown woman completing education
completing tasks entering into a
successful marriage and all that had a
strong connection a strong relationship
with her dad and and it just started
building value in fatherhood like no one
I had ever seen you you were the first
one I ever saw do that thanks well one
of the things that I do is I take
fathers behind their kids eyes so I I
help them see themselves as their kids
see them and that's very different you
know there are a lot of people writing
and saying do this do this do this but I
believe once you understand how your
kids see you parenting is a lot
different it's more challenging but it's
simple but any doubt that can do it
because once a dad realizes that their
kid sees them as bigger than life like I
said the man who has pure gold that they
need and they won't extract a little
piece here and there it's transformative
and and that's what I'm really
committing the the next
segment of my professional life is in
teaching encouraging inspiring dads how
to be to their kids who their kids want
them to be wouldn't you have loved it if
somebody came along Dave and said to
your mom and dad this is how Dave sees
you and this is what he wants for you he
wants from you I mean it would be
wonderful you know because then then
they would just hopefully deliver what
you needed yeah it's a different thing
okay
doing four things any father can make
dramatic changes in their kids life
regardless of the kid's age what are the
four things and is that really true
of course it's true right we're never
written it is that a trick question one
other thing that I've done as a
physician is I research the heck out of
everything I write because we're under a
lot of scrutiny
and they're they're very
um Politically Incorrect which I love
the first one is you need to lead you
need to be the leader
um and a lot of mothers a lot of women
in homes hate that because to them the
word leadership connotes I'm just gonna
steamroll over you no no no no no
leading your kids well means being that
great example of how to control yourself
how to be kind how to make hard
decisions how to make life at home
um make sense how to help their kids
when they're faced with tough decisions
like you know the gender identity the
sexuality thing dads are the ones who
really make that
um who really help really influence
their daughters in having a healthy
sexuality and gender the other one is to
be the stabilizer in the home we never
talk about that dads are the ones who
can walk into chaos and they can Defuse
The volatility they cause everybody to
pause and then they regroup and finish
the lesson I'll never forget Dave one of
the things that you told me that I
thought was amazing and you can
corroborate this or not Rachel is it
whenever I was lying is whenever you
whenever you had you know you had to
reprimand your kids and they cry you go
back into their room and you'd bring
them a wet washcloth
yes
reconciliation yep that's stabilizing
you go into a situation which is
volatile uncomfortable then you take a
pause she goes to bed and then you
regroup and you close the problem
and so many dads don't know how to do
that and that's how you stabilize a
family so lead stabilize number three is
engage and a lot of dads don't know how
to engage and so I walk them through
that and by the way this course is easy
simple it's all videos 10 minutes long
do this this this this and you're home
free do this this and then the last one
is remain tenderhearted and again these
if you can even get two of these right
you're you're almost home free because
this is what your kids need and you
begin to deliver that to kids
particularly in this day and age when
kids don't know how to have healthy
communication healthy relationships
because they're they're on social media
all the time and they believe healthy
relationships are done over text or
through social media likes or follows
it's likes or follows and it leads them
so empty so that's why I believe if we
can encourage and teach Dad just to move
in a little bit
they're home free their kids will
succeed it's simple it's not that hard
any dad can do it and that's why I'm
going to be starting live coaching calls
with dads where I talk about a topic and
then I answer questions and I love it so
good so Meg what would you say to the
Dad that says Yeah well my teenager
whenever I do try to engage or move
forward they they walk away they were
jacked and they don't want it's like
they don't want any part
and they're a teenager but that doesn't
mean that they really don't want you no
and that's here's the thing the snarkier
the teenager the more they're screaming
Dad Dad please come near here's the
problem dads are sensitive and when
their teenage daughter looks like looks
at them like get away you creepy person
dads take it personally it's not about
dads it's about the kid feeling so badly
about themselves that's the perfect
opportunity for a dad dad to gently move
and ask questions sit and listen listen
listen and you'll be amazed how much
closer you get to your daughter it's
great when the pieces of research I read
on this uh 35 years ago probably uh
Rachel was a baby was uh we were working
with teenagers at the church and there's
a guy named Josh McDonald doing a bunch
of writing on it and he said uh be sure
to teach your dads as your daughters
move into teenage years you will either
give them hugs or someone else exactly
exactly they're going to fill the void
and that's exactly why they need that
attention eye to eye they need affection
hug them touch them but that's just when
dads pull away because they become
afraid of their teenage girls how many
times do you hear somebody say oh the
teenage years oh that it's going to be
terrible don't say that the teenage
years can be some of the most fun yeah
and and and just to affirm good
character you know treat your kids as
though they're the person you want them
to be it's good Meg if you want them to
have integrity say I am so proud of the
Integrity you showed here I'm so proud
of the courage you've showed here don't
affirm you know all their Sports nut
kind of stuff affirm Great Character
they will grow up to be that person it's
really good really good yeah celebrate
that and celebrate that we had the
opportunity this last weekend with
everybody together the whole family
seven grandkids 15 dogs that felt like
there were only four but they were
everywhere and um you know and and food
flying everywhere it was just it was a
wild thing but I mean we get the
opportunity to stop and celebrate uh one
of Rachel's just one coolest camper at
the VBS thing and so we're like hey
let's watch the video of her getting
that and everybody gathered around her
little chest are sticking out you're so
cool you effect because you're there to
clap for her and say you go girl you can
be the strong woman and strength looks
like this but that award is based on
character exactly not getting an A or no
or or being that yep yep that said maker
you're amazing amazing so again you guys
Meeker parenting.com for all resources
thanks Meg thank you we love you Meg
thanks for being here
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today First John 3 17 but
if anyone has the world's goods and sees
his brother in need yet closes his heart
against him how does God's love abide in
him
Audrey Hepburn said giving is living
if you stop wanting to give there's
nothing more to live for
very cool hey folks finding a high
quality real estate agent can be tough
it can even be tougher when you're
trying to find one in another city or
even another state if you're relocating
you already got your hands full you need
a pro in your corner and we for years
have vetted our endorsed local providers
our elps and they're high performing
really strong
excellent real estate agents that we
call them Ramsey trusted because our
team trusts them yeah they're trusted
people trust them get it Ramsay trusted
yeah they're all over the U.S and no
matter where you are or where you're
going they're the top in the business
and they're going to take great care of
you they didn't get their license last
week and they're not your uncle Charlie
or some doofus at the church they're
really people that know things going on
in the real estate business they've got
a proven track record of selling and
helping people buy bunches and bunches
and bunches of houses over a long period
of time ramsesolutions.com agents
ramseysolutions.com
agents Alex is with us in Chicago hey
Alex welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Ramsay how are you doing great man
how can we help
so I'm in a little situation in which I
was hoping to get both your opinions on
uh I'm currently 22 years old I work
full time as a data scientist I own a
business and I'm currently getting my
master's degree in computer science
and um
the situation I'm in right now is I'm
unable to
have full capacity in each three of
those things in my graduate program my
in my work and my business with that in
mind I kind of want to drop one of those
or two of those and focus on
the other two full-time results I could
fully reach my full potential either my
job or my graduate school or my business
with that in mind I was wondering which
of those three you think I should drop
how much are you making in your in your
business the business that you own
so at the
we recently started making profit we're
currently profiting about 20 to 27 000 a
month divide that by two because I'm a
partner okay so I'm making about 10 to
13 and a half a month and how much are
you making in your full-time job
70 000 plus 10K bonus okay
a year
a year yeah and you're making 130 000.
own your business twice that
uh yeah a little over and uh
so the thing is is like it's a new
business
so it's still a little Chic around like
if it hits the fan tomorrow like the
business could close and like okay when
you're 32 10 years from now what is
going to get you to where you want to be
so realistically speaking I'm by 30 or
mid 30s I kind of want to be financially
free in a way in which I could do what I
want without having to look at the uh
without having to pay my bills or worry
to pay my bills
okay I'm you know I'm saying you
obviously are in the computer world
you're obviously in the technology world
a master's in Information Systems a uh
you've uh your side hustle is that and
your day job is that so what do you want
to be doing when you're 32.
by 32 I Really Wanna
expand this business and time should be
a full-time business owner uh
what is the business
so the business is we consult uh
companies on best ways to connect with
gaming influencers but we do that in a
very data we're very heavy on data
compared to our competitors and that's
what separates us okay you understand
that won't be in existence when you're
32.
oh
oh I mean nothing about that yeah I mean
four years ago that didn't exist
right
don't you think I mean you're you're on
The Cutting Edge of all these things you
the the rate of change now are you going
to be in an information systems yeah but
I mean is it going to be doing that oh
absolutely not I mean you know a decade
ago think about what we were barely
getting what we were there's a lot of
opportunity
the rate of change in your world is is
blinding so all you got to do is ride
the wave of change and be owning
something that is Consulting something
in that digital world and I think you've
got the brains to do it after talking to
you you're obviously very bright Alex
for your graduate program do you feel
like your degree is going to
significantly change your income your
opportunities
uh in regards to day job so in the world
of data science a lot of people in there
that are in a really high position
usually go to extremely well-known
schools or have a master's degree in
statistics computer science or something
along those lines yeah so if I really
want to like ignore the business aside
just focusing on my job
it's best for me in the long one to get
a message but you don't want to you
don't want to work for those companies
you want to own your own thing when
you're 32 you should
yeah you're absolutely right so I guess
a job is like more of like a backup plan
per se
I mean there's a lot of there's no real
wrong answer here you could dial all
three back some
and keep doing them all three you could
drop the day job pretty easily as long
as you can keep the cash flowing on the
on the side hustle and finish up your
Masters and then continue your
entrepreneurial uh you know growth and
and you know your product lines are just
going to iterate over a decade in your
world
um and I mean data science has become a
front and center any company that is not
uh it is not in not concentrating on the
management and Analysis of data is going
to be out of business in the next five
years it's two front and center to make
all of your digital everything work I
mean everything we do with YouTube
Google analytics uh all of our Spotify
connections everything we're doing what
you're doing there with in the gaming
world but we're watching influencers and
watching what our stuff does what works
and what doesn't and uh and then so we
don't you know it's not accidental and
and so we've got data scientists in the
building here that are helping us crunch
those numbers and take us there so Alex
Oh put them put them back on oops okay
all right uh how much how much do you
have left in your graduate program
so my graduate program finishes next
August uh the tuition is about sixty
thousand dollars but I have money from
the business purely satisfied my
progress in the business so far is I set
that aside to pay off my full tuition
but I'll graduate debt free okay so you
have one more year left basically of
school to get your Masters and you're
22. go finish it I would finish it yeah
so I would focus on that
um and honestly Alex tell me if I'm
wrong but I'm like your business is
doing great so I almost would put more
time and effort into that you're making
more money there and God forbid
everything hits the fan do you feel like
you have enough
connections and all of that to go get
another job if you needed to making 70.
in 20 minutes well I think I would say
that's I I assume yes would you say
that's correct Alex
yeah absolutely I networked heavy my
undergrad so I could definitely find
another job so what I would yeah so I
almost would if you yeah I would finish
the degree
and work on your own business and again
if something happens in six nine ten
months and
the business fails you can go get
another job
um so yeah that that's where I lean Alex
when you're asking if if you should drop
one
or two which one would you drop I would
drop that one right now but I would
finish that degree because that's going
to be even more marketable for you
after you have that if the job if your
business you know something happens
I'm not even worried about using the
Masters to get the job I think finishing
the Masters will put the tools in your
belt that'll help you become the
successful entrepreneur you want to be
because I think you're actually learning
things that are usable they have
utilitarian value and so
um yeah I think that I think it's good
education it's a good education and a
good field and I would lean into it and
and it's helpful in the job market
though when you have that you're more
marketable with that like he was saying
yeah in that world yeah she's right with
the data world I don't disagree
um but I don't think he's going to be
working I think he's going to decade for
someone else in a data science position
I think he's going to be doing other
stuff yep that's great but but anyway I
could be wrong so hey good luck with
that brother thank you for calling in I
don't know that we're of any help at all
but we try that's what we do good show
Rachel well done Austin Ben James Zack
Andrew will everybody in there good work
good work the deuce Booth dudes are at
it again we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]